we spent the entire month of march and
april yes
months of march and april trying to
convince people to not
cash in their money the ramsey
personalities did 458 media hits in
those two months that's right
and the primary message was stay calm
don't pull your investments out that's
exactly right
did a ton of them things were bad they
they were scary it was tough and we tell
them to stay true
follow the process we've been here
before this too shall pass
this two shall pass we've been here
before we don't get hurt on a roller
coaster if you don't jump off in the
middle of the ride
that's right we we went back and talked
about 9 11
talked about the sars epidemic those 709
depression recession y2k y2k we
we gave them history black monday 1987.
the days that the stock market fell and
the people were screaming and carrying
on that's right
and we tried not to shame them or make
fun of them during the times that they
were the most scared but just calm them
down and say don't take your money out
because if you sell at the bottom you're
going to feel stupid when this recovers
and it's going to recover and it's going
to recover this fall we did
that's what i said no you can go back
and pull the podcast dave ramsey said it
i will be back in the fall
that's right and you're going to feel
stupid if you took your money out i
remember you saying it
what if you found out you seem to have
know something
well we're sitting there both looking
the same article something come on
s p closes at a record erasing all of
the last pandemic losses
the s p 500 caps a furious
51.5 rally that began in late march
and set a new record today recovering
over 100 of any losses
that it lost during the pandemic since
february 19th so from february
19th down into march into late march at
dove and dove and dove and over domino
and by today and it's not even fall nope
100 recovered wow
so far will it go down again
yes yeah sure will sure will will it go
up again
yes it changes the only thing you can
count on
and this is where investing comes in
this way you know it requires being a
grown-up
and not a crying little sucking your
thumb little kindergartner in the corner
that's okay if you're a kindergartner
it's not okay if you're an adult that
doesn't work
no you're right and this thing you have
got to
have a vision where there is no vision
the people perish
you've got to look out into the future
and you've got to say
is the pandemic or y2k
or 9-1-1 9-1-1 recovered in 57 days
i haven't counted up the number of days
yet but from the bottom of this
probably not far off probably about 50
something days maybe 60 something days
and i'll have to go back and look at
when the bottom was but that's about
what it was
but the fear i want you folks listening
to remember how
tight your throat was how your stomach
was halfway up into your chest
how your heart was beating how you were
checking your 401k balances every
morning
like you were checking covet cases and
like you were looking for a tornado to
come at your house
you're looking on the weather channel at
the number of covet cases in your state
the number of coveted cases in your
county and you're looking at your stock
market go down
and you were addicted to fear yeah
because that's what you were sold
for lack of vision people perish
and i'm not i'm not making fun of you
i'm just saying i told you so
and so you've got to learn these lessons
part of maturity is being able to look
past
what's going on and take what looks like
a disaster
and say it is temporary yes
it is temporary it is temporary
it is temporary it could take two years
to come back
it could take two months to come back
but will the pandemic completely destroy
the us economy is the
logical critical thinking skill you have
to develop
no well it didn't it's a hundred percent
back as of tuesday
the s p 500 closes at a record erasing
last of pandemic losses wall street
clawed back
the last of the historic frenzied losses
unleashed
by the coronavirus as the s p 500 closed
at an
all-time high tuesday the benchmark
index
notched up a modest 0.2 percent gain to
beat its previous record high set on
february the 19th
before the pandemic shut down businesses
around the world
and knocked economies to into their
worst recessions
in decades well that's an overstatement
it's not the worst recession in decades
it might be one of the shortest
recessions in decades
but it's not the worst a worse one is
one that goes on and on
and on and on and on and on and on and
on we lost 40 million jobs
20 million of them are already back to
work and some of the ones that aren't
back to work don't want to be
for different reasons right now because
they're collecting much money
by not working right yeah yeah and so
you know we got the government
interference in our economy and you see
what happened with that
so guys there are lessons to be learned
in these kinds of things they're
spiritual lessons they're emotional
lessons they're financial lessons
they're wealth building lessons
and you've got to start looking at this
stuff and go really where
are we today yeah and we kept saying
what do we say we doctor john lonnie
said facts are your friends
you do not you do not make good
decisions when you're drunk and when
you're afraid
well it's really important to remind
yourself as you look at this
and see this article um and to hear this
and to know it
and i think you know the lessons that we
go through we get a chance to learn from
them
and when you apply wisdom it becomes
knowledge right
and wisdom for yourself but just hear
this and understand
it and then start to grow and
understanding this process of investing
of what's going on
but for goodness sakes don't rely on the
media to give you your reality
you've got to keep your hand on the
pulse and know what's going on well the
reality was the stock market was going
down
but the the the what the media was
telling you was that the world's coming
to an end right
chicken little is here the pandemic is
going to
ravage the planet it is ebola everyone's
going to die
two million people are going to die
uh they don't teach math in med school
apparently
no so there we go and you know
it's just the whole thing is you know
well i'm so happy that these companies
have recovered
because that means the jobs are coming
back and that means the folks that need
a job and want a job and are willing to
work are going to have a place to work
they have a place to go yeah once they
get out of their home right
and uh once their economy starts to open
up
and so forth i'm still i'm in such a
bubble because we've been back to work
here
with a thousand of us in this building
for months
we were off for about we were off we
were working from home for about five
weeks
and since then we've all been back uh
we've not had a positive case in the
building uh since july the 19th
and uh so about a month uh and now
without a single positive case out of a
thousand people we had 17
so 1.7 percent got the covet
flu at one time or another zero deaths
right
and we're all at work um and we're
you know we're with each other every day
there our cafe is open
um you know and uh you know we're not
being
completely reckless unless you do it by
some of your standards who are people
and some of you haven't left your home
yet
so uh and yes i am making fun of you so
it's time to come
out of your cave it's time to come out
of your cave america
this is the dave ramsey show